what's cool about this show is
simultaneously you get to turn
like your brain off but then also you
have to have like
almost like a phd to understand who
these characters are
where they're coming from and where
they're going as the actors
do you guys have like um white boards
with interconnected lines about like
tips and like the history and all that
stuff because i imagine it can get a bit
confusing
how do you guys deal with this what
i mean all of it time travel seeing the
dead
the way that i work is we get the
scripts you know i read the whole
episode
once maybe twice but usually once and
then i kind of have to hone in
on on like the allison scenes and then
kind of what the work that i have to do
there
and so you know i i like forget things
that happen to other people because
there's so many stories and so many you
know different
journeys that are happening all at once
so it definitely can get a little
confusing in moments especially in
scenes where we all come together i'm
just like
wait where were you and where are you
coming from
in season two the umbrella academy is
blasted back in time to 1960s dallas
and must reunite to put a stop to a new
doomsday threat
all while being hunted by swedish
assassins
what caused the apocalypse
you did
but not alone i was part of it
you got angry lost control and you
blew up the moon it slammed into earth
wiping out everything
ellen we really get to see uh vanya's
character
evolve and change and you have the
unique
i don't want to give away but your
storyline here is unique among all of
your
siblings what was it like for you
getting to play this different side of
her
it was so nice you know banya at the
beginning of the new season is
is quite different than the last season
and in many ways she felt like
you know establishing a bit of a new
character in a way because
the end of the first season we see her
release
a lot of energy a lot of repressed
emotions and anger and trauma
it doesn't benefit the world because she
does blow up the moon
but we find her in the beginning of the
second season and she's
you know she's lighter she's happier she
she's more open she can connect to her
emotions she can connect to
you know other people she falls in love
for the first time
and then going on her journey throughout
the season was uh
was incredibly enjoyable and fulfilling
as an actor
all right a quick rundown luther super
strength klaus can communion with the
dead
allison can rumor anyone to do anything
except she never uses
it i heard a rumor you punched yourself
in the face
[Music]
what was it like for you guys getting
all getting back together like what was
the first
scene do you guys remember shooting for
season two the first one we all did
together was actually the
the big opening sequence when we see all
the nuclear bombs and stuff going on
that was the first time we were all
actually together
on the set which was great it was really
it was really fun like
that's the best thing about the show you
know is the the time where we're all on
set together it's the time we have the
biggest laughs you know
so yeah it was good